we begin with a dramatic escalation in
tensions between china and taiwan and
rising fears of a military confrontation
on sunday taiwan celebrated its annual
national day with a show of might there
were aerial demonstrations and a parade
featuring military hardware that display
of the island's defense capabilities
capped off a very tense week china flew
a record number of fighter jets towards
taiwan's airspace and china's president
delivered a speech again demanding
reunification taiwan and its allies
including the united states call this a
provocation but china says it is taiwan
and the u.s doing the provoking
now analysts are concerned that these
rising tensions are shifting the status
quo in the region china views taiwan as
part of its territory but taiwan has
been self-governed since 1949 and is
vowing to stay that way
this is what taiwan's president sainguen
said on sunday
the people of taiwan will never give in
to pressure
we'll continue to bolster our defense
and demonstrate our determination to
defend ourselves to ensure that nobody
can force taiwan to take the path china
has laid out for us
and we can speak now to wen t sung a
lecturer at the australian national
universities college of asia and the
pacific in the taiwan studies program
and he focuses on trilateral relations
between the u.s china and taiwan he's
joining us from taipei today welcome to
our show i want to ask you about what we
saw in the last week we saw taiwan
putting on a show of military might
during national national day
celebrations over the weekend but china
has also been sending a record number of
fighter jets close to taiwan as well
why are we seeing the situation escalate
now
i think the broader background issue is
simply that the taiwan issue is getting
a lot more international attention
lately and it's something that china
doesn't really want to see
we've been seeing countries like
australia us japan and others as well as
g7 really are increasing in becoming
more vocal in terms of showing their
concern for peace and stability in the
taiwan strait
beyond that though i would say that from
the chinese side they are playing to
both the external audience and the
domestic audience
taiwan for example taiwan's opposition
party the kmt has recently just had a
new leadership election uh with the
leader swearing to office on october 5th
uh just last week
so um it's a period of time when
opposition in taiwan is going through a
soul-searching or rethinking of the
china policy at this juncture so it kind
of makes sense for beijing to be showing
some muscles in the hope of shaping
their preferences and not uh taiwan's
opposition and by extension taiwan
ruling parties china policy directions
in ways that they can like to see
well i want to ask you about taiwan's
perspective here because taiwan is
vowing to defend the island from china's
pressure but it doesn't want a military
confrontation as well so what does that
actually look like what does that mean
for taiwan
i think taiwan is trying to tell people
that you will remain pragmatic in its
relationship with china and also that
you will try as much as they can to
uphold the status quo in cross-road
relations
so if we judge by uh president tainwood
of taiwan her national day speech
recently she mentioned the four
commitments
it's kind of long and worthy but the
main ideas are that taiwan will protect
its freedom to rule itself he will
cherish his heart and democracy and that
he has no plan to unilaterally change
the status quo and any change should
happen will have to be decided
democratically by the popular will of
the chinese people so what does that all
mean
i think in policy terms it means that
she will not initiate any major change
on her own
any change should come about we have to
come
bottom up from the popular will of
taiwanese electorate i.e
through the form of a referendum for
example
now if you know anything about taiwan's
electoral system and special referendum
it's a very long very high threshold
process that means that any change
however unlikely it is in the first
place
any change will be slow which means
there will be enough time for uh prior
notification and potentially
negotiation with both the us and china
so not to say she'll be pragmatic and
there'll be no surprises coming from her
okay we'll talk about the u.s
perspective in a moment but first i want
to ask you about china's view here
because china's leader xi jinping has
also been speaking in public about
taiwan so i'd like to play you some of
his remarks from over the weekend at a
speech
marking the anniversary of china's 1911
revolution let's listen in
the historic task of the complete
reunification of the motherland must be
fulfilled and it will be fulfilled
achieving national reunification by
peaceful means
best serves the interests of the nation
as a whole
including our brethren in taiwan
okay so xi jinping vowing reunification
but by peaceful means so how do you read
what he said
so uh the commitment to reunification is
part and parcel of the china dream which
has been xi jinping's defining governing
narrative for so long so there's no
surprise there
there's also something about how he's
not gonna he's gonna punish
pushers or promoter or towing dependence
again same as before so what i'm going
to look for is variation from what
happened before and i think what's
interesting is that he tried to
show a bit more moderation as well as to
try to bring back in strategic patience
as the overarching thinking about taiwan
policy
so if you look at his speech he talked
about how
peace verification remains the best way
remains in the best interest of the
chinese people
it also said another thing
which is that the taiwan problem
occurred because of weakness of china
and therefore the town problem will also
go away with the great revival of the
chinese nation so that tells you that
he thinks with growth in chinese power
china will have a better chance to
solve the taiwan problem so to speak the
user language and so that means we can
china can show some more patients and
wait uh until terms become more variable
to china rather than try to rush through
the process using mutual escalation or
even war
well we have to talk about the us's role
in all of this as well you said taiwan
is getting a lot of international
attention the former australian prime
minister tony abbott says he doesn't
believe the u.s can sit by and watch
china quote swallow up taiwan do you
think that's true
i am
cautiously optimistic
about that i think taiwan is definitely
very important to the united states and
to the world as well more generally
speaking and i think town was important
for two reasons both for its strategic
interest
as well as its
position into the values discourse by
that i mean
strategically taiwan sits at the heart
of the first island chain unless a
number of societies stretching from
korea japan taiwan philippines all the
way down to australia
taiwan is at the center of that along
that area lies a lot of key us allies as
well so if taiwan were to fall into
chinese control then u.s major allies to
the north japan and what have you as
well u.s allies to the south countries
like australia they'll be separated and
that will inflict a huge dent in the
credibility of the u.s alliance system
in asia so that's a major problem and of
course when it comes to values
biden has been talking about
multilateralism and how values-based
diplomacy is at the center of that now
taiwan is the foremost liberal democracy
in a chinese-speaking world so if taiwan
were to be fall into chinese hand
without u.s doing anything it's hard to
imagine u.s credibility ever to recover
it is a sensitive situation indeed wenti
song of the australian national
universities college of asia in the
pacific thank you for joining us
well taiwan is trying to boost its
defense capabilities amid the rising
threat dw spoke to students taking part
in a high school military training
program that's supposed to encourage
young people to enlist once they
graduate
training with wooden shotguns in school
is part of yey you ching's everyday
school life she's in the first batch of
students doing a special military scheme
at this private high school
she first joined the class because she
thought the uniform was cool but what
she might face could be a war with china
after graduation
taiwan's defense minister said beijing
will have the capability to launch a
full-scale invasion by 2025.
this is it's only four years away i'm
going to join the military so i'm a bit
scared because it seems like the war is
so near but we can only face it if we're
in the force
chinese leader xi jinping has failed to
reunify taiwan last week beijing sent a
record number of military jets into
taiwan's air defense zone the worst
military tension in four decades
taiwan's readiness for war is now a key
issue
the self-governing island is facing a
shortage of soldiers as it transitions
towards an all-volunteer force
the defense ministry launched the junior
reserve officer's training scheme with
local high schools three years ago this
school now has 140 students in the
program and is the only school that
takes female students
my parents were initially against my
decision to train as a military officer
because i must cut my hair short they
are conservative and think girls should
look feminine
there's a stereotype that only men can
be members of the military but now is
the era of gender equality women can
defend our country too
the girls train the same ways as the
boys to the surprise of teachers they
show more determination than the boys
are girls asked to do the same training
as the boys i'm very surprised and
thrilled
as more and more girls join the program
they will become the next generation of
our military
and they are the elites
after three years of in-school training
serving in the military is no longer
about the uniform yay chang is hoping to
get into the military college and join
the air force after she graduates
no one wants war
but as the cross-strait military tension
worsens
defending our country isn't just a
slogan anymore
we really have to act upon it
i want to defend taiwan and my people
because they are like my family
these girls might soon be on the front
line as threats from china grow
you